[Música]
en france 24 es momento de doblar de
ciencia y tecnología soy valentina torre
sánchez y es un gusto acompañarlos en
esta ocasión iniciamos en california
puntualmente de la ciudad de los ángeles
hasta hace algunos años pensar en
implantar microrrobots en el cerebro era
posible únicamente en historias de
ciencia ficción ahora una empresa
emergente llamado bio not lapse está a
sólo dos años de realizar un ensayo
clínico en el que estos micro aparatos
serán inyectados en los cerebros de los
participantes
lo que hace la tecnología de micro
robótica lo que hace bien es que permite
trabajar en puntos que no se pueden
alcanzar y alcanzarlo repetidamente con
la trayectoria más segura posible
provocada para condiciones localizadas
como cáncer tumores accidentes
cerebrovasculares
acumulación de placa aterosclerótica
dolor localizado y muchas otras
condiciones existe una necesidad real de
tener un mecanismo de control remoto
micro robótico preciso que pueda tratar
una condición solo en un punto
específico los micro robots serán
guiados dentro del cerebro con imanes
puntualmente unas bobinas magnéticas que
están fuera del cráneo estarán
conectadas a un computador que maniobra
el robot hacia la parte afectada del
cerebro y lo retira por la misma vía los
responsables esperan usar el robot para
perforar quistes llenos de fluidos
dentro del cerebro cuando los ensayos
clínicos inicien en dos años y si el
procedimiento resulta exitoso podría ser
usado para tratar el síndrome de dandi
walker una rara malformación cerebral
que afecta a los niños con la formación
de quistes del tamaño de una pelota de
golf que se inflan y aumentan la presión
dentro del cerebro desatando una serie
de condiciones neurológicas peligrosas y
lo que están viendo es uno de los
diseños de bio not este modelo en
particular está optimizado para la fen
extracción lo que significa en términos
simples hacer un agujero en el quiste
con ese proceso defenestración lo que se
busca es restaurar el flujo normal de
fluidos en el sistema nervioso central
lo hemos probado en grandes animales
como ovejas o cerdos y los datos
muestran que la tecnología es segura
para los humanos de hecho todo ha sido
compartido con la gpda
continuamos en eeuu porque en la ciudad
de burlingame en california la compañía
meta antes conocida como facebook abrió
su primera tienda física en el lugar
buscará exhibir productos como gafas y
visores de realidad aumentada según
expertos la tienda permite que metas a
distancia un poco de redes sociales y
anuncios que podrían parecer engañosos
cuando estoy de mes
no hubo una gran multitud esperando la
apertura de la primera tienda física de
meta pero los congregados asistieron con
entusiasmo cada allá de si este edificio
será el primero del estilo del apple
store es histórico y somos los primeros
clientes estoy muy emocionado y
orgulloso
la tienda está en berlín game california
cerca de los laboratorios de meta que
desarrollan los hardware de realidad
virtual y aumentada en exposición sus
últimos productos como cascos inmersivos
y gafas de realidad virtual
en nuestra tienda puedes experimentar
pues tu portal y ravens orlando
meta quiere analizar las reacciones de
los clientes en relación a sus
expectativas no quiero jugar a juegos de
disparos quiero ir a visitar lugares
donde no he estado antes
me gusta mucho portal porque hacemos
llamadas familiares de su tenemos
familia en todo el mundo así que es un
buen producto a tener y tenéis para
accesar meta y sus competidores han
invertido fortunas en tecnologías de
realidad virtual con la esperanza de
diversificar el modelo de negocio basado
en ingresos anuncios en web y
aplicaciones como facebook instagram o
whatsapp para meta en el último
trimestre los ingresos alrededor de la
publicidad supusieron el 97 por ciento
del total se calcula que la realidad
virtual y aumentada será un mercado de
500 mil millones de dólares anuales en
los próximos años y meta está dispuesta
a perder hasta 10 mil millones de
dólares este año en sus laboratorios de
realidad para desarrollar el futuro
vamos ahora hasta londres donde un
colectivo de artistas músicos y
científicos creó una experiencia
inmersiva en la que el objetivo es que
los participantes cierren los ojos para
ver cosas si suena contradictorio pero
se trata de un espacio donde las luces
estroboscópicas y el sonido envolvente
hacen que los visitantes vean coloridos
patrones la experiencia también está
disponible en cardiff y belfast y
edimburgo
stream versión es una experiencia
inmersiva increíble que describimos como
inigualable de hecho la palabra que se
usa con más frecuencia para describirla
es indescriptible
como una colaboración entre equipo
brillante de mentes líderes en
tecnología arte música filosofía
neurociencia y antropología esta
iniciativa se basa en una teoría acuñada
por el neurocientífico británico william
gray wolter llamada revelación por
parpadeo que básicamente señala que las
luces intermitentes brillantes pueden
crear alucinaciones visuales lo que los
neurocientíficos llaman alucinaciones
inducidas estroboscópica mente la teoría
indica que la luz parpadeante impone un
latido al ritmo del cerebro
especialmente a su parte visual pues lo
que sucede en la dream machine es que la
luz está entrando con ese ritmo alfa
natural del cerebro
también es un ritmo que tendemos a
observar en el cerebro cuando las
personas se sienten relajadas
y al hacer esto digamos todavía no
entendemos completamente pero esto da
lugar a estas vividas experiencias
visuales que tiene la gente
los tipos de patrones que ven las
personas parecen estar relacionados en
cierto sentido con el cableado profundo
de su corteza visual entonces en cierto
sentido es casi como si el cerebro si
estuviera revelando su propia estructura
interna en nuestras experiencias en la
dream machine así llegamos al final de
este espacio a ustedes muchas gracias
por su sintonía continúen con nosotros
que además en france24 france24 puntocom
[Música]